[MUSIC - Orchestra warming up]
When people think of the extraordinary breakthroughs
that are made in cancer research, they don’t
realize the harmony that takes place behind
that research.
In music, this only happens when notes work
together, build off each other, and combine
to create the perfect harmony.
In cancer research, data pieced together in
a specific way can lead to new discoveries
and treatments for cancer.
Now, thanks to the NCI Cancer Research Data
Commons, or CRDC, sharing data is becoming
more harmonious than ever before.
CRDC is hitting the right notes.... providing
access to many types of data: genomic, proteomic,
imaging, clinical trial, and more.
All in one place.
It is enhancing the way data are shared, through
a single cloud-based and expandable infrastructure.
One that empowers researchers to perform at
peak by working in real-time to explore and
analyze data, without the downtime of downloading.
And equips them with the computational power
that only comes with the cloud.
CRDC increases connectivity, allowing researchers
access to standardized and harmonized data.
To ask more complex research questions by
combining diverse data types across the CRDC,
or with their own, for integrative analysis
to increase our knowledge about cancer.
All further supporting the goals of precision
medicine.
All furthering the effort to accelerate biomedical
discoveries, without missing a beat.
The CRDC gives researchers a place where they
can work in concert, in sync, and in harmony.
Now that’s music to many people's ears.